buon an amazing physiological
combination of unique properties it is
rigid yet flexible lightweight yet
sturdy enough to support the body from
the time of Hippocrates bone has been
known for its potential for regeneration
and repair it is this extraordinary
regenerative ability that has led
doctors and researchers alike to study
its properties all in an effort to
improve and accelerate bone healing as
early as 1889 surgeon nicholas sen
reported using demineralized bone as a
vehicle for the delivery of antiseptics
in the treatment of osteomyelitis and
certain bone deformities in 1945 pierre
Lacroix proposed that a hypothetical
substance and bone was responsible for
initiating bone growth but it was not
until 1965 that dr. Marshall Urist
discovered proteins trapped within the
bone matrix were responsible for
initiating new bone formation he coined
this phenomena Auto induction now known
as osteo induction and named these
proteins bone morphogenetic proteins
today research into bone regeneration
and repair is alive and well with
continuous and exciting advances LifeNet
health is proud to be a leader in this
research with more than 40 patents and
technological advances like pad that
maximizes osteo inductive 'ti in
demineralized bone graft products bone
formation and remodeling is a continuous
physiological process which involves a
structural matrix specific biological
stimulants and stem cells
physiologically new bone is induced to
form when osteoclasts cells that
demineralize or remove the minerals that
make up the bone matrix remove enough of
the matrix to expose the bone
morphogenetic proteins and
other bone growth promoting growth
factors bone morphogenetic proteins
trapped within the matrix are capable of
inducing stem cells to differentiate
into osteoblasts cells responsible for
new bone formation since bone
morphogenetic proteins induce themselves
to differentiate into bone forming cells
they are referred to as osteo inductive
today technological advances make it
possible to reproduce the body's natural
demineralization process allowing for
the creation of osteo inductive medical
products the percent of the mineralized
matrix left intact after
demineralization is fundamental to
achieving optimal osteo induction when
the bone matrix is over demineralized
acid used during the process denatures
or removes the growth factors trapped
within it this results in lower levels
of active growth factors and proteins
and therefore lower osteo inductive
potential if tissue is under
demineralized growth factors trapped
within the matrix are not fully exposed
and as such are less capable of
interacting with surrounding cells to
rapidly initiate bone formation here we
see under demineralized bone this
section reveals an abundance of intact
matrix trapping the growth factors
beneath if the growth factors are not
unearthed so to speak they cannot
effectively influence new bone growth
tissue that is optimally demineralized
as an ideal level of residual calcium
this allows for the proper exposure of
growth factors and proteins resulting in
optimal osteo in ductility published
studies have shown restricting
demineralization to residual calcium
levels between 1 to 4 percent is
necessary to achieve optimal osteo
induction life net health pulls the
patent and proprietary process for
tissue demineralization to achieve a
residual calcium of 1 to 4 percent
therefore this product is only available
from LifeNet health to initiate the pad
process a technician enters the
appropriate weight and other associated
donor information through a proprietary
algorithm and nomogram the pad system
will take care of the rest within the
chamber acid is first pulsed in to the
bone
the acid penetrates the bone matrix
replicating the normal physiological
process of the osteoclast eating away
the minerals immediately following this
acid bath a buffer solution is
introduced via computer-controlled steps
the acid bath buffer sequence continues
until the bony wall of minerals is
removed exposing the growth factors
beneath a nomogram calculates the
appropriate demineralization level based
on the donor bone weight and density
using this careful computer control the
finished product conforms to a targeted
residual calcium level between 1% and 4%
pad the future of allograft bio implant
demineralization